how you doing guys welcome to the Reuben
report we have a bananas bonkers big
blowout show for you this week I have a
little announcement I'm gonna make at
the end but first I want to introduce
you to my my two esteemed panelists my
two favorite ladies of the TYT Network I
think you know who they are already ana
kasparian and kim Horcher yeah in don't
order other than that they were sitting
in this order first off Kim I just want
to say you're wearing some armor which
is really I'm ready to fight I'm ready
for war there will be a war today so
we've got Kim in armor and you're
looking very professional all right we
plan to people all right let's do this
so I want to talk a little bit about
Isis we did a story last week with Ben
and Jimmy about whether we in the media
should be talking about Isis when they
do these propaganda videos with the
beheadings and the burnings and all the
other awful stuff how much we should
actually talk about it because that does
that just strengthen them does that
strengthen their recruiting etc etc well
now our Justice Department apparently is
going to go after people who are
promoting Isis on social media we've got
a little more info for you John Carlin
the assistant attorney general for the
national security said that officials
could try to blunt Isis's violent PR
operation by trying propagandists as
terrorists he suggested the Justice
Department could bring prosecutions
under the law against providing material
support to a terrorist organization this
may be the first time a US official has
ever said that people who assist Isis
with online media could face criminal
prosecution okay on its head that sounds
pretty decent right we don't need them
to be using our tools like Facebook and
YouTube and Twitter and things of that
nature to promote this horrible stuff on
the other hand we all talk for a living
we talk about these things we report on
these things etc etc this seems like a
slippery slope for someone like you
right right so I'm not a big fan of
slippery slope arguments but I think
that when you start passing policies
that criminalize and prosecute people
for simply promoting a tear
organization through commentary it could
be really dangerous and if it's
commentary through social media under
what these officials are asking for hey
you know what you're in big trouble you
could be prosecuted I don't know if
you're gonna be tried for treason I
don't know exactly what the charges
against you will be but at the same time
people are allowed to have their
opinions even if their opinions that you
disagree with even if their opinions
that you find extremely violent or
destructive so for instance we allow the
KKK and white supremacists and neo-nazis
in the country to say whatever it is
that they want to say because we protect
their speech right now actions are
completely different so if you're going
out of your way to recruit people into
Isis if you were actually doing
something to physically help Isis I
think it's a different story but I think
commentary and speech should be
protected even if it's something that
you disagree with yes I'm a hundred
percent onboard that and there's a
difference of course between free speech
and calling for violence against people
but what do you think about the slippery
slope thing because to me it seems like
yes we might report on it I might think
it's important that someone knows what
they're up to so I could tweet a link to
an article that doesn't mean I'm
supporting them if anything I want to
show people this horrible stuff but then
there's the slippery slope to the
government could be like are you promote
what are you what are you going for here
well yeah I mean there's an important
differentiation which Ana just made but
at the same time I'm not sure if I buy
this like it seems like it's more
posturing than actually fixing the
problem and then there's also the idea
that a legislature usually moves way
slower than technology and then we have
a problem because of that this seems
like it's a little bit in the opposite
direction like it's too much yeah
do you think that the timing of this is
also we're like I feel like we live in a
time when nobody trusts the government
to do the right thing anyway the
government's spying on us all that stuff
NSA and all that so the idea like there
isn't enough trust there isn't enough
cachet in what the government's doing to
be like oh we trust that you're gonna
deal with this thing popular the timing
is interesting because we live in an age
where the government gets to do things
without real authorization right so
we're seeing certain executive actions
when it comes to foreign policy without
congressional approval and like that
yeah exactly so that's problematic to
say the least but I think that the
slippery slope is definitely possible in
a situation like this especially when in
the past we've done stories about people
who have been prosecuted for let's say
posting rap lyrics on their Facebook
page right officials will make the
argument that they're promoting rap
violent not rap violence gang violence
that this is dangerous that they're
actually going to carry out what they're
saying in the lyrics but it's speech and
and you really need some hardcore
evidence to prove that someone is going
to carry out a violent act or that
someone is inciting violence yeah so to
that point do you think we need to have
like a real debate about what free
speech is in this country and what
freedom of expression is because I feel
like with the Charlie Hebdo thing and
everything else we're not debate we're
not really talking about what really
most people I don't think understand
that the difference between what you say
and then inciting actions like things
like that yelling fire in a movie
theater like I feel like we have to have
like a real discussion about it but we
don't and then as you're both saying
then the government can just go ahead
and be like oh we're gonna do this
little Isis Twitter thing and who knows
where we end up yeah I mean a lot of it
it seems like it's reactionary to you
know just weird things going on I also
think people don't really understand the
difference between freedom of speech and
freedom of expression which one of them
protects you from you know the
authorities and the government the other
one is just kind of being a dick and
wonder is legal in one of them you know
yes right I think another really good
point is the fact that a lot of
Americans don't understand what it means
to be protected by free speech so for
instance if a company decides to fire
you over your speech they have the
ability to do that right a private
company free speech protects you from
any government action or you know strike
back if if you say something that they
don't like right all right what do you
think is this a slippery slope to the
government controlling the internet even
more than it already does or are we
actually gonna help stop Isis 3 means
like this let us know in the comments
right down below I cannot believe this
but according to my paperwork here there
is pornography on the computer you guys
heard about that did you did you know
about that I had no idea Kim did you
know about that I am shot sir
it's quite shocking and appalling yes
but apparently it's true and now Google
is gonna start cracking down on it at
least on their blogger service we've got
a little more info for you so this is
the policy that they're going to
institute now and then I'll tell you
about what they've been doing before
this starting on March 23rd 2015 you
won't be able to publicly share images
and video that are sexually explicit or
show graphic nudity on blogger will
still allow nudie if the content offers
a substantial public benefit for example
in artistic educational documentary or
scientific context and then the changes
that you're going to see to existing
blog so this is if you have a blogspot
account if your existing blog doesn't
have any sexually explicit content you
won't notice any changes if your
existing blog does have sexually
explicit or graphic nude images or video
your blog will be made private after
March 23rd 2015 no content will be
deleted but private content can only be
seen by the owner or administrators of
the blog and the people who the owner
has shared the blog with so just real
quick basically up until this point
bloggers did allow adult content so you
can get porn on blogger right now but
they all the person had to do the
administrator was just market as adult
and you just click check and you're good
to go
so they're cracking down on this stuff a
little bit my general thing with this is
that there's so much porn online and
Google's a big company like what are
they what are they is this like what is
the moral majority non-set like what are
they what are they going for here I
think that making sure that someone
checks off on a box indicating that
they're 18 or older to watch the content
whatever is fine and that's what okay
you guys can do that right but I just
like it's the Internet I would say like
82 percent of the Internet is
pornography that was a made-up statistic
obviously I'm exaggerating it's probably
closer to 92 it's probably but I think
that I just get scared with this kind of
stuff because the one thing that's great
about the Internet is how free it is
right and so whenever I give lectures to
my college students always tell them
like if you want to work in new media
there's a huge upside you don't have to
worry about FCC regulations you can cuss
if you want to cuss you can have
sexually explicit content you know
in some of your videos if that's what
you really want but YouTube crackdown on
that Google cracks down on that I mean
it's the same company but you get what I
mean and it's like we're adults let us
make the content that we think is
favorable to our audience and just not
policing us yeah I mean that's pretty
much how I see it I mean it seems to me
that if people want porn they're gonna
find it one way or another so if Google
just wants less clicks and they want to
make it more difficult so be it people
just go elsewhere you three I want you
all to know that tumblr.com does not
have these regulations that URL no ii
are.com you can blog whatever the
you want right early but you know look
this is just my hypothesis yeah and it's
just based on what I've noticed with
YouTube and advertisers people are less
likely to advertise on YouTube videos if
it's not family-friendly right so I'm
wondering if you know Google is having a
harder time selling you know Adsense ads
or whatever on some of these blogs
because hey you know what it might have
some sexually explicit content and it
might be difficult to sell ads I don't
know right I don't know what their
business model is there but it always
comes down to the money the advertisers
who are big who can't
handle some x-rated content grow a set
of balls people watch porn
people have sex
people have vaginas and penises and
we're gonna be fine I'm just I'm so
tired of having to tiptoe and walk on
eggshells because people have kids if
you have kids be a parent and
keep an eye on what they're watching if
adults want to post explicit content
they should be able to do it on the
Internet and advertisers again grow a
set of balls please well Anna just
answered my next six questions oh no you
know people ask often on YouTube why do
you guys do sex videos why do you guys
do drug videos I mean a lot of them I
just think are interesting but to Anna's
point people click on them just no
matter how much porn there is online
people still come to YouTube for people
to talk about porn or sex or whatever it
is and then ironically those videos do
pay out the least yeah so a lot of times
the things that are getting the most
clicks in this little digital world we
live in actually make us the least
amount of money which is a whole other
other topic altogether do you guys think
we're gonna look back at like the last
like
years as the golden age of the internet
because we just did the story a second
ago about the government wanting to look
at Isis on Twitter regulate some of that
stuff now we're talking about it with
bloggers and sex do you think that
there's we're entering the second phase
now I mean if we don't get net
neutrality yeah that was the Golden Age
and we're over it
yeah I'm already hearing though that
even this net neutrality think I heard
this long interview with Mark Cuban
yesterday and he was even saying that
the that the net neutrality that they're
passing isn't even gonna be as good as
what we all thought which is a whole
other issue yeah I think that people are
starting to realize that audiences are
transferring from television to online
and once that happens you're gonna have
governments and certain individuals
wanting to regulate it and wanting to
censor it and I think it's problematic
but I think that it's gonna be a lot
more difficult to do that with the
internet compared to what they did with
television yeah there you go on a story
like this even if you think it's just
silly because it's about porn really it
starts there and then it's what can the
regulations do down the road that's why
I think something like this is important
what do you think let us know in the
comments right down below all right you
guys all know Stephen Hawking the
brilliant and renowned physicist the
movie the theory of everything just came
out about his life he had some
interesting things to say about sort of
the future of humanity and and sort of
how we've evolved and how we may
continue to evolve we've got an
interesting quote from him right here
the human failing I would most like to
correct his aggression it may have had
survival advantage in caveman days to
get more food territory or a partner
with whom to reproduce but now it
threatens to destroy us all a major
nuclear war could be the end of
civilization and possibly the end of the
human race the quality I would most like
to magnify is empathy it brings us
together in a peaceful loving State I
thought this was kinda interesting cuz
it's nothing new here yeah we should be
better to ourselves and to our neighbors
and things like that
but sometimes when something comes from
somebody as bright as a Stephen Hawking
perhaps Kim we should pay a little more
attention dr. Hawking has also expressed
his concerns over AI becoming too
rampant and being able to control the
you know humans in general I guess
versus society in a way and it
kind of it's on both sides of the
spectrum in that way I don't really
agree with him on the AI thing but I do
pretty much agree with him on this we're
gonna kill each other yeah do you think
the robots are gonna kill us or we're
gonna kill each other first I'm actually
more concerned about the aggression that
he's talking about in his recent
comments because as someone who's on the
internet you do see a lot of that
there's a lack of empathy that I've
never experienced before in my life
maybe I was naive like you do stories
about domestic violence and people will
totally give others a pass for beating
the out of one another yeah and I
don't really know when that was okay or
when people thought it was acceptable
but I'll give you a quick example we did
a story about Afro man who is a rapper
literally hitting another woman in the
face because she had the audacity to get
up on stage and dance and have a good
time at his show she's a fan of his
right and so we put that video up online
of course we condemned his actions and a
huge population of people were like well
he was justified he was sexually
harassed by this are you kidding
me right now yeah he hit a fan in the
face for having a good time at his show
so like that aggression that's just one
specific example that aggression is
becoming more and more prevalent if you
ask me and it is problematic do you
think there's something about the online
yeah it's making it happen like so for
example back in the day if you had to
hunt for your food you could get out a
certain amount of aggression in a normal
way or guys that play football you're
getting out a certain amount of physical
aggression where now everyone's just
sitting behind their computer all day so
your aggression comes out in ways in a
something like that where it's so clear
like what's right and wrong yet you
still find yourself expressing
aggression because maybe you're not
getting out and in a very human way
people forget what it's like when
they're not face to face with someone so
like you don't realize there's a person
on the other end of this who is reading
this it has feelings and thoughts and
value and you know when I'm face to face
with you like there's no way I'd be like
you you know but yeah maybe if I you
would say that but like that's a
terrible example actually but you know
you forget that level of humanity and
empathy when you're not next to a human
and I think that
something we haven't evolved with yet as
as technology starts to evolve more and
more yeah
I think it makes a good point but I
think another part of it is the people
are frustrated right now you know people
have more student loan debt than ever
before it's really hard for young people
to find jobs and so when things aren't
going the right way in your life you're
looking for a scapegoat yeah and so I
understand that aspect of it as well but
yeah I mean if we had a little more
empathy and we understood the
perceptions of other people I think that
we would live in a much better society
so why don't our government the leaders
talk about that nobody really Bhama did
it a little bit originally you know in
2008 when he came in and he gave that
big speech and Egypt about understanding
different people that but we really
don't do that anymore right there even
from Obama all the way down is there
anyone that really talks about sort of
understanding your neighbor and all of
that why don't we do that well the
government doesn't lead by example at
all in fact I mean we demonize people
that are different from us on a regular
basis and so if you have leadership
spreading those types of ideas of course
it's gonna seep into the general
population when you treat all Muslims as
if there are all extremists you know as
a government you are sending a message
to your people it's the citizens and I
think that that's dangerous yeah all
right people we're gonna do a little
test here and you all be empathetic
Pleasant lovely and wonderful in the
comments right down below I don't want
to hear any about these two that's
it all right right there you know where
it is
subscribe comment now researchers at the
University of Michigan have found out
something that I'm pretty sure I knew
all along processed foods can often be
just as addicting as hard alcohol and
drugs the reason I think I know this is
because any time I have one Dorito I
have that immediate urge to eat a
thousand more and if I'm on a plane and
they give me just like a little bag of
something I want eight more bags like
that's actually a real thing and I don't
think I'm the only one that that's
happening to we've got a little more
info on the study the authors of the
study wanted to discover what foods were
most likely to lead to food addiction
they found that highly processed foods
were more likely to have the same effect
on the brain as hard drugs compared to
non processed foods like wheat fish and
other healthy foods just like other
addicts don't choose to become a dick
heroin or cocaine obese people don't
choose to be fat so I think this is
really interesting and it's exactly what
I was just saying before so let's just
start on that antidotal part do you guys
find that too that there are certain
foods processed foods that you have one
how many people say that about potato
chips all the time versus if you were
having a bowl of rice let's say yeah I'm
chicken you eat till you're satiated and
chicken rice yeah I mean that's why I
don't have Nutella at home if I have
like one spoon of Nutella that's it I
eat it with the spoon so it's just the
only way it's my right right sometimes I
just put it in a big bowl but I I think
that this has an evolutionary advantage
but unfortunately we live in a
completely different time where the
advantage no longer exists right so when
we were hunter-gatherers like we of
course want fattier food right right
because we need the fattier foods to
survive but now is plentiful yeah you
know and so we still want the same
things but there's an abundance of it
and we eat too much of it and then of
course we're not as physically active as
we were ages ago so yeah that's the way
it works right and by the way with all
this process stuff there's plenty of
evidence that they literally are putting
in flavors that they make up because
they make our taste buds go nuts so that
you just want more of them right mm-hmm
well I feel that way about sugar I'm not
sure about necessarily like the
processed food thing but there's sugar
in everything you'd be shocked like
things like that are supposedly like
healthy mothers nature's bounty
smoothies love it yeah I mean for me
they specifically target food that
tastes like Latino Latino I think we're
gonna have a gift for something made on
that one who do we blame for this like
is this our fault or is this do we blame
the corporation's do we blame the
government that told us to eat this
stuff do we blame McDonald's do we blame
ourselves for not being educated enough
I don't know if there's anyone you can
blame other than the companies that are
purposely making their food as addictive
as possible yeah um I know it's really
difficult to control yourself when you
want to eat the fatty food but I
the best way to combat what's happening
in the country is education right so
passing regulations that ban certain
sizes of sodas or tack certain foods
it's like putting a bandaid on a larger
problem a lot of people don't have
access to healthy food or a lot of
people are simply uneducated on what is
and isn't healthy so someone might see a
granola bar and be like yeah Duds
granola of course this is gonna be
healthy but the reality is grills like
one of the least healthy things that you
can eat and then they wrap it up in
sugar by the way we can't do something
on sugar without me mentioning my pet
peeve number one which is that in our
coke in our coca-cola we don't have
sugar in America oh yeah high fructose
corn syrup because corn is cheaper to
make sweet than sugar so you get a
Mexican Coke in America they actually
get sugar in your coke that is
completely bonkers
after the Latino thing I mean eventually
really like eventually it's going to
become looked at like an addiction right
if that's what your point I think in a
lot of ways we're as good as our choices
and you know what is subsidized what is
easy easily accessible what what is you
know the most attractive looking thing
and it's going to be maybe something
that's not good for you yeah I think we
got Anna's answer to this already but my
final thought on this is what food is
your guilty pleasure but I guess well
now is it some sort of Latino Nutella
for me I don't know my guilty pleasure
is like any type of chocolate cake
that's warm and gooey with like ice
cream so sugar I love sugar I can
confirm that's true because you've
brought everything to my house many
times Kim I like donuts yes I like
donuts donuts man they bring us Donuts
around here on waiting days like I can't
stop I know I shouldn't I can't but
actually my healthy addiction this one's
an actual healthy addiction Trader Joe's
has these mesquite almonds and their
almonds almonds are good I think
Mesquite's pretty good I like that I
think I'm doing all right
anyway do you love Latinos the 11 foot
sugar that was odd anyway what get to
York let us know it's right come on
what is the deadliest drug in America
yeah it's the one that is legal in all
50 states of course it is alcohol a
really interesting new study just came
out we've got the link to the study
right down below because it is really
expansive and we've only got a couple
minutes here on the YouTube so you can
check that out if you want more info all
right so let's give you some more info
on the study the authors of the study
assessed the comparative risk of death
that accompanies consuming everything
from weed to meth and found that weed is
even safer than they previously believed
researchers drew these conclusions based
on the margin of exposure which measures
the likelihood of an average user
accidentally ingesting a toxic dose the
lower the ratio the smaller the margin
for error and the easier it is to
consume a harmful dose okay now we've
got a graph for you and I'll lay out
what's going on here as you can see in
the chart weeds average margin for error
the red bar is much higher than that of
other drugs meaning the likelihood of
consuming a harmful dose is lower you
pretty much can't do it with weed the
margin for error for alcohol meanwhile
is very low reflecting a much higher
risk of harmful consult consumption and
we've got a little more info for you
take a look at this graph whoa
the government Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention study of drug
mortality rates which tallies confirm
causes the death puts a fine point on
how obviously backwards these drug laws
have become and here's where you can see
that very very clearly what are people
dying of tons and tons of people dying
from tobacco tons of people dying from
alcohol look at that the number on the
right Anna what do you make of that zero
on the marijuana I'm glad that more
studies are coming out proving that
there is no way that you're gonna die
from smoking marijuana
you're not gonna overdose from smoking
marijuana but at the same time I do
worry a little bit about some of the way
that these stories are covered because I
think it is irresponsible to say that
marijuana is completely harmless you're
not gonna die it's not gonna ruin your
life right but there are people that
become dependent and it does have some
negative impacts on their lives on their
productivity and so I want to see more
of those studies as well but I think
that this is something that we all
pretty much already knew right and I'm
glad that there's more scientific
evidence to
prove the naysayers wrong it's
ridiculous that there are some people in
the country thousands in fact that are
serving life sentences for simple
possession of marijuana we need to
change our laws regarding that just
based on evidence like this right so I
give up I give Obama a lot of but
he has done actually a pretty decent job
on marijuana laws pretty much the feds
actually still can come in and close
dispensaries here even in California
where it's medicinal illegal are you you
don't smoke marijuana all right I've
only had pot once and it was on accident
and it was a lot okay I was at somebody
who was a host on this networks party
and there were these brownies and I
thought they were regular brownies so I
had four weird after that so I mean you
must be like tripping balls
I remember taking an edible and I
thought I literally thought I was gonna
die they keep reminding myself it's just
marijuana it's just marijuana I just
write no weird I didn't so even that I
think is the point and even you're part
with edibles for yourself that you did
it right and did you want marijuana
venex no I'm done like I don't approve
why it's not that dangerous
I well Anna's right it's not completely
harmless like I did feel like I
shouldn't drive after this yeah but you
know I didn't I don't think I was in
danger of dying I don't feel like I'm an
in danger of being addicted right of but
changing my life in that way yeah do you
think the weed things already done like
to me it's happening as quickly as gay
marriage once gay marriage really became
an issue say like four or five years ago
I know it took a long time to get to
that point but once it really became
part of the national discussion it's
happened pretty quick I mean freaking
Alabama has it right Texas there's some
legal stuff going on down there so I
feel like weed is just gonna follow that
path absolutely I mean there's already a
lot of momentum for legalizing marijuana
for recreational use right now there are
ten states that are considering it for
recreational use that means that you're
not using it because you have cataracts
you're using it because you want to get
the munchies and sit on the couch and
watch TV and the government acknowledges
that they're cool with it which is great
but I mean think about this Washington
Colorado now alas Alaska DC organ these
are all places in the US
where you can purchase and consume
marijuana for recreational use and I
think that's a good sign yeah do the
weed people need lobbyists like to me it
seems like more I think they're getting
some lobbyists now and we've already
seen that in Colorado the tax revenue is
great so it's to me and this is
something that Republicans should be for
because if they really are for small
government you wouldn't care what
someone smokes in their bedroom right
and you'd be finding another way to get
taxes I think a lot of this is just
misinformation like the pervasive
thoughts that oh it's scary it's bad
stay away from it it's awful you know
but it I think if this is all based on a
very old propaganda campaign so you know
maybe we do need some lobbyists for this
cause yeah so then actually should we be
are we talking about this in Reverse
should we really be talking about how
bad booze is like I'm not saying we
should be going for prohibition again
but we don't really talk about that at
all those deaths are through the roof
drunk driving et cetera et cetera yeah I
think that we have a problem with
tobacco deaths and alcohol deaths both
substances are completely legal in the
country of course they're regulated to
some degree but you know I think that
there should be more education campaigns
out there that help those who are
addicted to both of those substances
because that's the big issue that's the
real problem here all right there you go
I would be for education not regulation
what do you think let us know in the
comments wreck envelope people
absolutely hate Congress how should they
hate them they have like a negative 642
approval rating which is almost
impossible but it turns out that a new
study is proving that women the women in
Congress are getting a lot more done
than the men surprise surprise let's
look at some info quorum which is a
start-up that analyzes congressional
relationships and policymaking found
that over the past seven years female
legislators have been more likely to
work with the female members of the
opposite party and more likely to see
their bills passed compared to their
male counterparts I'm not surprised a
little more for you okay so these are
average bills co-sponsored with each
senator of the same gender
so male senators on average got about
four of these bills out female senators
got six alright a little bit more also
keeping in mind that there are way less
women in the Senate than there are men
men introduced on average about 70 bills
women introduced 96 that
a pretty significant difference men got
an average about three bills out of
committee so that means it went the next
step to becoming a law or at least
getting to the President's desk women
got almost five and men got on average
about one and a half bills enacted and
women got 2.3 so by every estimation if
you just look at the empirical evidence
women are getting more done in Congress
you know there's a causality thing I
think is what you're gonna first tell me
here right no no you're not going to
tell me I'm you know and whenever I see
a study like this I have like questions
about standard deviation and sample size
I'm wondering if this is maybe that
there's so much fewer female
congressional representatives yes you
know that the experiment doesn't make
sense based on that right so okay so we
can't totally break down all the science
of it but there's a general theme here
that women seem for one reason or
another to be getting more done right I
think it's an interesting hypothesis and
I don't know for some reason this study
did raise some red flags for me but even
if everything in that study is true I
still don't think the results from the
women are that impressive right which
kind of speaks to how low our standards
are for Congress right and the reason
why there's a lack of bipartisanship
isn't because people are inherently bad
and they're unwilling to work with one
another it's because they have corporate
interests at play they have people
funding their campaigns and so even if
they genuinely feel strongly about an
issue they're not gonna be principled
about it because they got to think about
re-election and funding their campaigns
right so I get that I'm totally on board
yet everyone is bought and sold and
that's why Congress doesn't get anything
done and all that stuff but do you guys
think that maybe there is something
about the female mind just because men
and women have different thought
processes right that maybe is allowing
them despite all the corporate interests
to still maybe get some more done like
that I mean that's just what the numbers
are saying there are some stereotypes
that women are more empathetic than men
so that could probably factor into them
being willing to cross party lines and
work with others yeah so yeah I mean
there are things about men and women
that are inherently different there's no
question about that whether or not those
differences play a role in the study
I think is yet to be proven so I'd like
to see more you know research into this
and we'll figure it out but I think you
start getting into dangerous territory
when you say women in Congress are
better than men in Congress or you know
men in Congress are better than men
women in Congress I just think that
right now we don't know what any of
those bills were so we made me against
all of the bills that the women were for
probably not but you really have no idea
are you guys more inclined to vote for
women in general if you see if
everything else is equal would you be
more inclined to vote for a woman if you
didn't particularly care about either
candidate either way everything is equal
we'll start there everything was equal
which pretty much never I've never seen
that happened once yeah so am I just
more likely to choose a woman over a man
if you didn't particularly have a dog in
the fight then I'm not voting then you
wouldn't vote yeah interesting yeah
that's actually a really good point if
you have two candidates that are
basically the same why vote you're gonna
get the same result but no I don't think
that I'm more inclined to vote for a
woman as opposed to a man I think that
it really just boils down to the issues
but if let's say all the candidates are
exactly the same and the only thing I'm
voting on is a man versus a woman I
think right now considering how
underrepresented women are in Congress
sure I guess I'd vote for the woman
right so in and of itself you're not
going to necessarily vote for Hillary
right but I'm guessing you both might
vote for Elizabeth Warren but you would
say that's not a policy absolute because
always policy that has to be number one
you can't just be like I only want a
women in Congress because you don't well
Sarah Palin's a woman and she was crazy
Sarah Palin's a woman do you agree the
National Sleep Foundation recommends
that adults aged 18 to 64 get between
seven and nine hours sleep per night I'm
probably right in the middle that right
around eight I need my sleep I'm
enjoying a little siesta these days too
like 12 minutes I love it anyway a new
infographic has come out showing what
successful people from right now to the
past how much sleep they got so let's
take a look so there's some really
interesting stuff here Bill Gates
averages 7 hours of sleep which is right
sort of at the front end of what the
Sleep Foundation is recommending
billionaire Donald Trump Anna I know you
love Donald Trump am i right Donald
Trump he gets about three to four hours
of sleeps he then spent the day arguing
with eggs on Twitter Margaret Thatcher
got only four hours of sleep per day
this one I think is really interesting
Nikola Tesla who is the grandfather of
electricity slept for only two hours
each night Winston Churchill he did four
hours and then he knew the 90 minute nap
I want to talk about naps in a second
and interestingly and not surprisingly
politicians are the group of people who
get the most with more than nine hours
of sleep each night we know they're not
working and they're pretty much asleep
at the job so I don't know if that
counts in that so let's just start with
the personal angle like how important is
sleep to you guys can I have problems
getting to sleep like I would like to
sleep more but I'm definitely a night
person and I worry at night and I can't
sleep and wake up early for the Rubin
report taping but it is important like I
feel a lot better my mind moves better I
look better I feel like I functioned
fine on four to five hours of sleep I
average between five and six and when I
sleep more than that I'm actually groggy
the entire day so all of these studies
frustrate me a little bit because
everyone's different yeah and so I don't
like it when people tell me oh you're
only getting six hours of sleep it's
actually destroying your cognitive
abilities no it destroys my cognitive
ability is when I've slept eight hours
and then I wake up and I just want to go
back to sleep
right and everyone's your to your point
I mean that graphic shows the plenty of
highly productive people that are
getting very little sleep
although among those who don't get
enough sleep you have Margaret Thatcher
and Donald Trump I don't know if I was
just pulling well you know we can throw
the graphic back up for just a second
we'll just keep talking so people can
see who else is on there I like the
Tesla fact right there two hours that
sounds right think about the that
he was getting done I had some serious
problems psychologically as well yeah
remember that time I mean he's a
brilliant man undoubtedly but he did
have his issues by the way so Barack
Obama gets six hours which is a little
on the low side yeah go ahead I just
have to make a point about Berlusconi
the reason why Berlusconi
they got two to four hours of sleep is
cuz he was prostitutes don't let
you sleep they charge when you're
sleeping what do you guys make a little
what do you make of the if you're with
the prostitute you know you mean like if
you charge in two hours no I don't know
what you mean I would say generally
prostitutes they charge you for the
whole time so if you're gonna sleep
through it you know your value you got
it right well Berlusconi was
specifically known for his bunga bunga
parties yeah which I loved covering him
he was great what do you guys make of
the politicians they get a lot of sleep
they don't work they get a lot of sleep
they pass laws so that they're come on I
feel like I chose the wrong career I
love what I'm doing but I feel like I
would live high off the hog if I was a
politician so you become likable by the
way I don't really want to do right like
a mid-level congressional somebody and
not everybody would know about you but
you could sleep on yesterday I was like
toying with the idea of serving on the
Los Angeles City Council I'm like it
sounds like it'd be fun it right yeah
and if I know one thing about Ana it's
not like she has a lot of controversial
things she said that could possibly
derail her who knows anyway how much
sleep do you guys get how important is
sleep in your day-to-day operation let
us know in the comments right down below
which youtuber makes the most amount of
money think about it for just a second I
know I know you're all thinking me but
no not me and I know the next thought is
pudy pie right everyone knows booty pies
huge he's playing video games and beauty
as in pew pew the point is it's not him
either
yeah you know who it is it is a woman an
anonymous woman up until now at least by
the name of DC toy collector what does
she do on on the YouTube she unboxes
children's disney toys that's it
yeah let's take a look hey guys Disney
collector here and today we're gonna
have some fun with sparkling play-doh
and Disney Princess since we have here
six different colors we're gonna be
making six different sparkly dresses one
for each of this princess first one to
get a sparkling dress it's gonna be bad
so let's remove the glitter glider dress
they fit a sign and start working on the
new dress all right so that is literally
all she does she has dozens and dozens
of videos unboxing Disney toys she has a
sort of angelic voice I suppose guess
how much she's making on YouTube a year
five million dollars which is just above
what your pop yeah just teeny right
above nerd alert just right money I
ain't gonna lie not even gonna lie oh
yeah so she's making an incredible
amount of money you know what I thought
was interesting that's just interesting
in and of itself but now it has come out
that she actually is a porn star we've
got an image of her her name is sandy
summers and she went through incredible
lengths to not have her real identity
revealed because obviously she's
reviewing these toys that her children's
toys so we assume that it's a lot of
children that are watching the videos
she also disables the comments on her
videos by the way which I'm guessing she
does intentionally so that people that
might want to be just saying awful dirty
perverted if kids are going to the
video they don't have to see that stuff
so she's really done every precaution
that she could possibly do to keep this
thing on the up-and-up but she got outed
and they figured it out because of a
scar and some other stuff who cares is
what I would further we can talk about
the YouTube angle first but who cares
someone's in the sex work business
they're also making videos on YouTube
who cares
we love demonizing people who are in sex
work industry who have ever posed nude
in their lives anyone who's been a
victim of revenge porn
we love victimizing them and it's
ridiculous and so I don't care but I
know that there are probably a lot of
mothers out there who watch these videos
who care so I think it makes sense that
she's making a lot of money these
unboxing videos are genius and I'm angry
at myself for not thinking about it
first so can you explain a little bit
about why you think they're genius
because I watched a couple of them in
preparation is and they're so idiotic
but there is something as I said angelic
about her voice the same as in but what
do you think is genius so it seems
ridiculous to you because you're not
interested in the product but for people
who are considering purchasing the
product watching these
videos give you a better sense of what
you're gonna get okay are you going to
get your money's worth so some people do
this with technology let's say they buy
a new phone and then they unbox it and
they show you all the different like
gadgets that it comes with and it just
makes sense to me because you want to
know what you're paying for a lot of
people shop online so I mean I like to
buy clothing online and I would love it
if some of the retailers that I buy from
put out some videos like unboxing it so
I know what I'm gonna expect when I get
into the mail right so just so you know
video had 209 million views 290 watching
a girl unbox Disney toys I get all of
Anna's reasons there but what do you
make of the unboxing thing so I've
watched her channel before you told me
to watch it yeah and I had I was
interested in who she was - she made it
kind of a mystique like who is this lady
is this other channel her husband blah
blah blah I think it's cool I mean when
you gave me the story I didn't I didn't
think the story was you know oh she used
to be a porn star that the story was
look at this amazing look how well this
is doing and you know I think it's
popular because it's hitting a few
different points like one there's the
unboxing thing where you see something
new and you get that like that hits
pleasure centers and then there's also
playing with toys which is also fun I
like Disney I have a childlike sense of
wonder that was the most honest thing
I've ever heard you say I have a
childlike sense of wonder I do to him
alright so I'm with you on all that but
you think there's a weird danger in
fetishizing stuff you know anything just
this idea I get it for the clothes thing
it kind of makes sense because if there
was a girl who you trusted and she was
like and this feels right and we have
similar body but just this idea of with
the tip with all the phones and
everything that it's just all about
stuff like welcome to America I mean
that's capitalism we're obsessed with
stuff I'm obsessed with stuff I'm female
addicted to retail it is what it is
so is it dangerous I guess yeah
specially considering credit card debt
and all that but overall I'm 100% giving
her a pass do you boo I'm so happy she's
making this kind of money and I'm angry
at myself for not being smart enough to
think about it right well here's the
deal like this is a very simple concept
here's a toy look at the
Toye wow it's really when you look at
more you know complicated topics like
existential issues deep philosophical
worries it's harder to one tag and title
that to get people who are interested in
this abstract concept it's a toy there's
the toy easy right so it's sort of
marketing 101 all right well I'm gonna
end this with I'm gonna put you guys
both on the spot so I'm glad we didn't
focus on the porn aspect of this because
I think it really is irrelevant whether
she's whatever she does in her personal
life I don't really don't think it
matters but do you guys ever fear that
something you've done in your past could
affect your future because that this
thing could come back to haunt her now I
am overly cautious when it comes to
certain things so I've obviously said
controversial things on the show and I
take full ownership of them and when I'm
wrong I'll take ownership of that as
well in terms of like nude pictures or
videos I have a really strict policy
against ever taking or doing any of them
so I have nothing to worry about I'm
fine
a woman with nothing to fear again I
haven't taken any like naughty pictures
either at least I mean yeah and I
haven't done it all I'm saying is you
can't trace it to me so don't even try
all right on that note I want to thank
Anna and Kim
[Music]